the distinction between tapping into the
executive line was the habitual mind
it's not that the executive mind is
unimportant it's very important a lot of
times we do conscious processing at the
front end of a decision but the
unconscious mind is much more
influential than we had originally
understood and this is something that
when we talk about trying to tap into
that it's really tricky because if I go
up and I ask you you know why did you
you know pick this restaurant you know
you're under the you know the customers
under the exact same miss understanding
has the marketer that the customer
assumes that it was a conscious decision
and the customer assumes that they had a
good reason and they make one up you
know they make one up right when you ask
them and the the conscious brain is like
it was like the husband that wants to
take credit for everything that the wife
is doing you know it's like you know
just assumes that somehow you know I
must have had a conscious reason for
doing this but the reality is you know
it may have been the whole reason you
may go to you know this restaurant
versus that restaurant is it was a right
hand turn you know the other restaurant
is the left hand turn across traffic and
you know at that just you know for some
reason I don't I prefer to avoid that
and then once I did that right hand turn
two or three times then that right hand
turn became automatic so the idea that
i'm trying to get across as yes you want
to understand what's going on with the
executive mind but you really want to
recognize that your success is going to
come from winning the habitual mont I
don't think about what search engine i'm
going to use I don't go hmm I wonder
which one is best i wonder if someone
come up with her with a new search
engine that i should I google I mean it
is like whatever I think I googled stop
you know if I want to look up something
I wiki it's done you know can somebody
else come up with a different one yes
but for them to win me they've got
they've got to help me build a new habit
they've got to get that the thing that I
do before I go to wiki or before I go to
google and that's that's the real
competitive battlefield and that's the
thing that I think most companies don't
understand and they continuously think
oh I have a better product you know I
have a better you know widget I have a
better you know I have a better search
engine and and they get shellacked but
they get shellacked because they
understand that they've got to overcome
this this amount of inertia that has
come from the number of times people
have repeated that decision in the past